d'accord
toujours à Grand Central elle est là elle est
là mais elle est avec un gars
désolé mec il vient toujours je ne sais pas d'
accord eh bien je vais t'envoyer un texto l'adresse
j'espère vraiment que tu viendras
c'est moi excusez moi
excusez moi maintenant vous pourriez vouloir  ce retour
Nick c'est cassé
merci beaucoup en raison
des règles de sécurité de l'autorité portuaire, la
gare est en train de fermer et rouvrira
à surveiller euh excusez-moi
et qu'est-ce que cela signifie que la gare
est gelée, cela signifie que vous ne laisserez aucun
train le matin  mais je ne peux pas attendre
aussi longtemps
la ligne pour les taxis à l'avant d'accord mais je
n'ai pas besoin d'un taxi parce que je rate mon train
euh puis-je utiliser ce billet sur une autre
gare n'aidera pas dix gares à en fermer
deux